سيجتمع القديم esp footon المشي
نقود هذا الألبان يمكننا اليقظة
موقع القتال مناجم تيموثي نعم ذلك
كان الإصدار من أي مدرسة في
المستقبل الرقم مزود الكمال
الظروف
[موسيقى]
أنا حميم ، أنت تتحكم في نفسك وأزرع القهوة
ولدت فكرة بركان بالنسبة لي
حلم الحصول على نبتة ذات يوم
القهوة وأن أكون قادرًا على تناول قهوتي
منذ 28 عامًا بدأت في التأسيس والأول
100 نبات
[موسيقى]
الآن نحن في مجال يسمى
سيرو دي كورونا نحن في سفوح التلال
من بركان الماء أنا هناك حيث
لدي أرضي السنوات الماضية
كان الطفح الجلدي أكثر تواترا قليلا
كل 15 دقيقة ينفجر
لمدة 5 دقائق ما هو هذا الكبريت
هو عنصر غذائي هو عنصر غذائي ل
مصنع وهذا ساعدنا كثيرًا
[موسيقى]
ستيفن دورف ورقائق صدئ وقهوة
طعم خاص من القهوة
الارتفاع ثم ما يساعد في
ارتفاع لأن القهوة لديها المزيد
الحموضة في مصادر الحموضة و
نكهات الفاكهة الموجودة هناك
دائمًا ما يتيح لنا ذلك
جودة قهوة أفضل
[موسيقى]
تيموثي خاص على مقياس 6
الاسم جيرسون أو أنا باريستا
محمصة ولدينا
مقهى في أنتيغوا غواتيمالا
نحن موجودون في إحدى المدن
أشهرها في غواتيمالا
هنا يمكننا تصنيفها على أنها تقريبًا
يمكنك أن تجد مكة القهوة
المقاهي أو المقاهي في كل زاوية تقريبًا
اشترينا القهوة مرة واحدة
عام مع عدم وجود مناجم تيموتي دون تيمو
لديها واحدة من أفضل أنواع القهوة الطبيعية
من العملية الطبيعية التي اختبرناها
[موسيقى]
بركان الأرض cofepris
خاص و binner ويسلط الضوء على الإسبانية و
تيموثي وأنا ممتن لذلك
لتلك التجربة من قبل الدولة
أنا أفعل والفرص التي
أعطاني القهوة التي يجب أن نلتقي بها
أصحاب مقهى جوناس
من القهوة من سلسلة القهوة وذاك
أدى إلى تجارب جيدة
أيضا من خلال زراعي
و
[موسيقى]